bonjour à tous le san diego comic-con
vient d'avoir lieu il ya eu beaucoup
d'annoncés concernant marvel alors je ne
suis pas trop vidéos news d'habitude je
n'aime pas trop faire ça mais là je vous
avoue qu'il ya quand même pas mal de
dinguerie et enfin j'ai envie de vous
dire donc voilà il est grand temps qu'on
en parle donc bienvenu dans cette vidéo
chill où nous allons juste échanger
parler un petit peu de ces nouvelles
annonces et on commence du coup bas sans
tarder avec la première information
cruciale nous sortons désormais de la
phase 4 black panther wakanda forever
prévue pour le 11 novembre 2022 et le
dernier film qui va clôturer du coup la
phase 4 et sincèrement pour moi il était
temps rien de bien méchant vrai mais la
phase iv est une phase un petit peu
particulière puisque c'est un peu une
phase une bis on va dire un renouveau
après endgame il a fallu réintroduire
plein de nouvelles têtes plein de
nouvelles thématiques de nouveaux
concepts et voilà c'est très sympa les
origines story tout mais au bout d'un
moment on a besoin de concret on a
besoin d'une direction et c'est
désormais chose faite la face qu'à
attiser énormément de choses mais voilà
au bout d'un moment il faut mettre en
application tout ce qui a été teasé et
enfin nous y arrivons à ce moment donc
voilà j'ai vraiment hâter et d'ailleurs
il ne faut pas non plus oublier que la
période de covin n'avait pas non plus
aidé au bon développement de la phase 4
voilà bref du coup logiquement si c'est
la fin de la phase 4 cela annonce aussi
bas le début de la phase 5 est justement
marvel nous a tout dévoilé au comicon on
va pouvoir en parler la phase 5 va
débuter avec antoine et la guêpe cantou
magna le troisième film dédié du
personnage de scott langue et je peux
vous assurer que ce n'est pas un hasard
bien évidemment nous savons que le film
explorera encore plus en profondeur le
champ quantique modok que tout le monde
attendait pour être le grand méchant du
film d'après certaines rumeurs a été
officialisée mais surtout si antoine 3
possède une grande importance c'est
parce que c'est le premier film qui va
nous introduire officiellement à l'écran
kang le conquérant je vous le dis ce
n'est pas du hasard il y a une belle
symbolique derrière tout ça kong sera
présent dans le premier film de la phase
5 et nous savons désormais qu'il jouera
un rôle crucial
pour l'avenir du mc eu en tant que grand
vilain mais nous y reviendrons plus tard
alors qu'est ce que nous pouvons déduire
rapidement sur antoine cantou manière
déjà au moment où je vous parle sachez
qu'il y ait eu des visuels d'antoine
canto magna partagé au comicon il ya des
chances que cela sorte dans les jours à
venir mais pour le moment nous n'avons
rien dans la logique il est clair que
l'on va aller plus loin concernant le
champ quantique la phase 4 de marvel
explore largement les dimensions
adjacentes et le chant quantique en fait
partie maintenant que janet van dyne est
revenu cette dernière de par son absence
dans le royaume quantique on s'est
énormément et va permettre à scott et la
guêpe de mieux maîtriser les lieux
limite peut être même de cartographier
nous savons également que le chant
quantique est liée au temps c'est
forcément quelque chose qui intéresse
kang concernant modok ce qui est
intéressant c'est que c'est un humain à
la base qui a été modifié en super
ordinateur et la chose encore plus
intéressante à souligner c'est que c'est
un scientifique qui est derrière tout ça
qui est derrière la création de mode hoc
et pour une réécriture pour le mc hugh
kong pourrait être carrément à l'origine
de cette création on le rappelle vite
fait comme ça mais quand on est un
seigneur de la technologie issue du
quarante et unième siècle c'est un
brillant scientifique dans les comics il
est même à l'origine de robots et autres
bottes qui agissent pour lui tout comme
les timekeeper en gros dans l'eau qui
bref et on n'oublie pas également de
rappeler quand man 2 nous tease est une
cité cachée dans le royaume quantique il
s'agit peut-être du royaume de modok
mais il se peut clairement que cela soit
aussi chrono police le quartier général
de kang et petit mot sur cassis langue
nous la voyons en tenue sur le premier
poster du film depuis le début de la
phase 4 marvel nous introduit petit à
petit les membres des young avengers et
cassis en fait partie voilà continuons
avec les gardiens de la galaxie volume 3
je lai secretin les jeunes de côté pour
le moment car je compte en reparler
prochainement dans une prochaine vidéo
et surtout bas il n'y a rien de bien
nouveau sur la série actuellement juste
que ça sort en gros printemps 2023 du
coup les gardiens le film promet d'être
très lourde car c'est censé être la fin
de des gardiens telle que nous la
connaissons il ya même une bande annonce
qui a été partagée au comicon bien
évidemment nous n'y avons pas accès et
du coup il ya eu plein d'informations
aussi qu'ils ont été partagés
premièrement le film devrait pas mal se
tourner autour de roquettes nous
devrions avoir ses origines et cela
sous-entend certaines choses déjà dans
le fond requête est un personnage qui a
beaucoup souffert de sa condition
animale qui dit fin des gardiens dit
également des morts dans l'équipe et
faire un focus sur les origines de
roquettes cela sous-entend clairement
que le personnage peut mourir et surtout
ce qui est intéressant c'est que le high
evolutionnary a été officialisé pour
celles et ceux qui veulent en savoir
plus le haut évolutionnaire c'est un
scientifique obnubilés par l'évolution
des espèces et la génétique il cherche à
manipuler les espèces pour créer des
êtres parfaits et pour ce faire il a
notamment utilisé des animaux qu'il a
modifié en humanoïde
je pense que vous commencez à faire le
lien le aïe evolutionnary est à
l'origine de rocket raccoon pour le mc
mais ce qui est intéressant également
c'est que vous savez qu adam warlock va
enfin apparaître à l'écran ce dernier a
été teasé dans les gardiens de et dans
les comics adam warlock est très liée
aux a révolutionné ricard oui adam
warlocks et la représentation de
l'évolution vers le parfait pour plus de
détails le haut évolutionnaire et celui
qui va donner à adam le nom warlock dans
les comics et il va génétiquement le
modifier avec la pierre de l'âme pour en
faire un être parfait et notamment un
héros pour sa planète la counter une
planète qui reprend tous les codes de la
terre et où les créations duo
évolutionnaire vive bref nous aurons le
temps d'y revenir dans les mois à venir
mais ça promet de belles choses
le aïe evolutionnary est un grand
personnage de marvel et il sert
clairement d'éléments clés reliant tous
les personnages des gardiens 3 la saison
2 de l'eau qui possède désormais une
période de sortie l'été 2023 ils vont
certainement refaire comme pour la
première saison mais pareil nous allons
y revenir un peu plus tard dans la vidéo
car cette saison deux paires
relier quand même certaines choses blade
a été officialisé pour le 3 novembre
2023 et pareil bas comme toutes les
productions il y a des choses
intéressantes à souligner comme vous le
savez certainement marvel fonctionne en
partie avec les thématiques par exemple
docteur strange est liée à la magie donc
c'est plus facile de le lier avec wendat
notamment ou america chavez d'un autre
côté sam le faucon et nouveau captain
america c'est clairement les super-héros
plus terrien plus classique donc il est
plus facile de leur groupe et avec des
personnages comme bucky our sharon
carter et cetera bref blade c'est
intéressant car il nous a été teasé
rapidement dans eternal que quand il est
venu à la rencontre de dane whitman qui
allaient empoigné l'épée de ses ancêtres
bled c'est la venue des vampires et de
tout ce qui est surnaturel et sombre
genre les loups garous et c'est en gros
c'est une nouvelle thématique blade
c'est un héros sombre et violent black
knight soit dane wissman c'est pareil et
du coup marvel va réunir tout ça pour
nous proposer dû contenu sans oublier
également que where he walked by night
arrive pour halloween et qu'il est très
liée à blaye dans cette thématique vu
que c'est un loup garou et on n'oublie
pas moon knight qui a beaucoup partagé
avec ses héros aussi dans les comics
blade permet de nous amener une
continuité pour moon knight d'ailleurs
car si on relativise les personnages du
type monica rambo ou encore le miss
marvel seront dans ce marvel si hulk
pourrait bien apparaître dans captain
america ou dans les productions liée à
daredevil ce genre de chose quoi mais
moon knight ap ar bled c'est très dur de
le voir ailleurs donc voilà les midnight
sun vont commencer à se former gentiment
par le biais de blade on continue avec
la série iron art prévue pour l'automne
2000 23 alors iron hard comme l'a
dévoilé le trailer de black panther
wakanda forever cette dernière sera dans
le film iron art c'est un peu une mini
tony stark dans le sens où elle est à
fond dans la technologie et elle s'est
confectionné sa propre armure je n'ai
pas grand chose à dire sur elle
actuellement si ce n'est que c'est
encore l'introduction du new young
avengers la série dédiée à agatha
harkness possède désormais un réel titre
open of kaos et possède également une
période de sortie et l'hiver 2023 alors
c'est très intrigant car agatha je
trouve que c'est un peu le projet
outsider de marvel car agatha elle n'est
relié à personne à part one that i want
d'abba elle est absente là de plus ce
qui me gratte la tête c'est que
forcément s'il ya une série sur agatha
on se dit que c'est le développement du
passé de marvel avec les sorcières de
salem possiblement merlin et cetera les
ancêtres de dane wizmann également mais
au final à quoi cela va servir si agatha
possède sa propre série c'est qu'elle va
faire avancer le présent également vous
voyez ce que je veux dire ce que je
comprends personnellement c'est que l'on
peut avoir possiblement une série mêlant
à la fois le passé et le présent agathe
a plein de choses à nous apprendre sur
son histoire mais elle doit avancer
aussi ce que je me dis c'est que
peut-être et je dis bien peut-être avec
la pseudo mort du rwanda le sortilège
que la scarlet witch a lancé pour
emprisonner agatha se serait levé
libérant donc agatha agatha pourrait
donc donner naissance à un nouveau
covenant de sorcières d'où le covan of
chaos ce tout en s'inspirant de l'époque
où elle faisait partie des sorcières de
salem nous révélant donc le passé
magique de marvel et introduisant de
nouvelles sorcières mais bon tout ça ce
n'est que théorique daredevil fait
officiellement son grand retour avec la
série daredevil born again prévue pour
le printemps 2024 et c'est une grande
première la série fera 18 épisodes alors
je vous parlais un peu du regroupement
par thématiques avec blade de tout à
l'heure et bien c'est un peu quand même
le même délire avec daredevil matt
murdock va apparaître en costume dans la
série she hulk les deux personnages sont
très liés dans les comics vu qu'ils sont
tous les deux avocats ça aide aussi je
ne vous le cache pas mais également nous
savons que matt reviendra également dans
la série dédiée à eco prévue pour l'été
2000 23 je vous laisserai voir ma vidéo
dédiée à la fin de hawkeye car on n'en
parle pas mal mais pareil échos et
daredevil sont très liés dans les comics
mais cela ne s'arrête pas là car la
série daredevil born again nous confirme
également le grand autour de wilson fisk
le caïd c'est l'un des méchants ultime
de daredevil et cela nous permet de
faire un regroupement échos a été élevé
par wilson avant de se rebeller matt est
liée à eco et à wilson et en plus de
cela chez yolk eux se joint à la partie
aussi est ce que vous voyez ce que je
veux dire il est de grandes chances que
daredevil born again ce point un petit
peu on va dire l'oeuvre finale entre
guillemets de cette thématique
regroupant du coup tous les personnages
que je ne vous mentionnez un peu dans le
style de miss marvel monica rambo
captain marvel et nick fury qui se
regroupent pour faire du coup de marvel
ce et en plus la série pourra nous
donner également une origin story de
daredevil le born again c'est clairement
une référence à la série netflix qui
n'est plus canon mais également
daredevil quand il apparaît dans no et
home et bien il a déjà ses capacités de
super héros il est déjà actif entre
guillemets donc la série va permettre de
répondre à tout ça
enfin pour la phase 5 nous avons captain
america 4 new world order prévue pour le
3 mai 2024 et seulement deux mois après
le film thunderbolt va sortir pour le 26
juillet 2024 ça je vous le dit d' avance
mais marvel a quelque chose en tête bon
déjà captain america 4 ça va être
l'avènement de faucon en tant que
capitaine accompagné de bucky et de
sharon qui va certainement jouer sur
plusieurs tableaux puisqu'elle est
désormais power broker le film
thunderbolt sera quant à lui l'avènement
de l'équipe des avengers un peu plus
dark recruté par valentina les gradés
fontaine rappelez vous cette femme agit
dans l'ombre depuis le début de la phase
4 pour former une team secrète de super
héros nous avons déjà eu à l'écran john
walker
recruté en tant qu est agent elena
belova a également travaillé avec elle
et plusieurs héros sont censés faire
partie de la team à l'avenir en fait là
moi je vous le dis mais captain america
4 et thunderbolt il ya des chances que
cela soit l'équivalent d'un mini
avengers un peu comme l'était civil war
à l'époque c'est très étrange que les
deux films sortent dans une très courte
période de temps surtout quand on sait
que les deux films
on traiter d'éléments qui sont reliés
entre eux il ya un parallèle très
intéressant à faire et pour ça il va
falloir que nous parlions de la phase 6
une ébauche de la phase 6 de marvel nous
a été dévoilé et c'est clairement la
plus grosse dungy parmi toutes les
annonces la phase 6 devrait s'ouvrir
avec un film quatre fantastiques prévu
pour le 8 novembre 2024 et par la suite
deux film avengers ont été officialisés
avengers the gang dynastie pour le 2 mai
2025 et avengers sicre et wars pour le 7
novembre 2025 alors par où commencer
marvel est en train de nous reproduire
ce qu'ils ont fait à l'époque avec
infinity ward et endgame ces deux films
avengers était le grand final de la
phase 3 de la saga infiniti et il n'y
avait qu'un an de différence concernant
les sorties la la dynastie de gang et
sicre et wars c'est pareil c'est le
grand final des trois nouvelles phases
la phase 4 5 et 6 de la saga multiverse
et les films ont seulement sept mois de
différence par rapport au film avengers
the dynasty of kong nous comprenons très
clairement que nous allons faire face à
l'apogée de kong en tant que grand
vilain de la phase comme je vous disais
kong sera présent dans atmane qui est le
premier film de la phase 5 et tout ça
c'est très symbolique gang va apparaître
petit à petit jusqu'à cet avènement la
série law qui nous permet en même temps
d'avoir une origin story pour le
personnage également car l'histoire est
très clairement reliés à ce dernier mais
surtout ce qui est incroyable a souligné
c'est que pour celles et ceux qui ne
savent pas la définition de dynasty
cette succession de souverain d'une même
famille ce qui signifie très clairement
pour moi que le film va explorer en
profondeur l'histoire de gangs et de ses
nombreuses identités la famille de gang
s'est lui même en fait toutes les
identités de gangs sont des souverains
et ce dernier nagy avec personne d'autre
à part lui même donc là c'est obligé
pour moi que nous ferons face à ram a
tout ay morte us kong iron ladd et
possiblement scarlett centurion ainsi
que kid il artus et ensuite bassi
crétoise vous savez ce que ça veut dire
on en a déjà beaucoup parlé je vous
invite à voir ma vidéo dédiée aux
incursions où on a mis le doigt dessus
mais voilà c'est la guerre multi vers
celle dont nous allons être témoins
plusieurs univers vont rentrer en guerre
pour la survie de chacun et gang est
clairement un personnage clé dans tout
ça je vous le rappelle comme ça mais
sicre et wars a été introduit dans l'eau
qui celui qui demeure a déjà vécu sicre
et wars c'est la guerre multi vers celle
qui l'a gagnée par le biais d'alliances
et j'aimerais vous ramener quelque chose
dont je vous parlais déjà à l'époque du
grand final de l'eau qui sait que nous
sommes dans une boucle en fait la fin de
la saison une de l'eau qui s'est à la
fois le début et la fin de tout le
multivers se relance à la fin des temps
sylvie tue celui qui demeure est une
nouvelle guerre multi vercel arrive nous
allons vivre ce que celui qui demeure a
vécu jusqu au moment précis où il fait
face à loki et sylvie c'est une boucle
comme je vous disais sauf que cette fois
ci bien évidemment il ya de grandes
chances que ce soit différent car voilà
nous sommes censés avancé et mettre un
terme à la saga multiverse après la
phase 6 imaginez un seul instant la fin
de la saison une de loki mais cette fois
ci avec les avengers dans la citadelle
de la fin des temps pour confronter kong
ce serait grandiose et la boucle serait
bouclée et du coup par rapport à ce que
je voulais vous dire concernant captain
america 4 c'est qu'il ya une belle
symbolique par rapport à wenger se campe
dynastie et avenger sicre et wars car
par définition sicre et wars c'est des
avengers eux qui s'affrontent pour
sauver leur univers est en fait captain
america 4 et thunderbolt cela va être le
même délire mais à l'échelle terrestre
c'est à dire qu'il ya de très grandes
chances que nous allons être témoins
d'une confrontation entre avengers et la
team des dark avengers les thunderbolts
c'est une sorte d'avant-goût par rapport
à 6 crétois rebonds et enfin on n'oublie
pas que doctor doom va lui aussi à
paraître très prochainement et ce
dernier aura un énorme rôle à jouer
c'est lui qui est à l'origine de six
crétoise dans les comics il ya des
rumeurs comme quoi il apparaîtrait dans
black panther 2 et il est obligé que ce
dernier soit introduit dans le film des
quatre fantastiques
lui aussi ça va être un sacré morceau
mais bon nous reviendrons sur lui plus
tard il y a tellement de choses à
théoriser désormais il y a tellement
d'éléments qui ont été introduits avec
ces annonces c'est juste incroyable
mais bon je pense que l'on va s'arrêter
là je suis trop heureux de ces annonces
un vraiment je pense que marvel avait
des choses à prouver le manque de
direction commençait à peser pas mal sur
les fans et là tout nous dévoiler permet
d'enfin d'avoir une direction est de
savoir où on va nous reparlerons bien
évidemment de toutes les oeuvres qui ont
été énoncées à l'avenir je n'ai pas trop
parler notamment de secretin vdn aux
marnaises car je vous prépare justement
une vidéo là dessus qu'il devrait sortir
dans les jours à venir et pareil le
prochain pourquoi sont ils si unique est
en préparation vous avez voté dans
l'espace communautaire il sera dédié à
doctor doom bref je ne sais pas trop
quoi rajouter plus juste je suis trop
content le des 23 qui arrive en
septembre devraient aussi compléter la
phase 5 à la phase 6 et nous amener
d'autres projets qui n'ont pas encore
été annoncés apparemment il y aurait
huit nouvelles productions qui sera
annoncée au des 23 donc voilà ça promet
encore du lourd et puis on attend les
teasers et trailer du comicon ils ont
dévoilé black panther et chiottes mais
on n'a pas eu les premiers visuels de
ant man ni la bande annonce des gardiens
de la galaxie à voir si ça sort dans les
prochains jours et puis sur ceux
j'espère que ma vidéo vous aura plu
n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit pouce
bleus n'hésitez pas à laisser un petit
commentaire avec ce qui vous a le plus
et puis bien évidemment n'oubliez pas de
vous abonner à la chaîne là on se
préparera pour de belles années et vous
pouvez compter sur moi pour vous parler
tout ça et faire un max de théorie que
le lie à grave soit avez-vous cet argot
rock allez ciao tonnes
[Musique]